My history is your history,
your history is my history,
and our history is our story.
We share the same place
in time and space
in the world, in today's society,
and we owe it to each other
to know more about
our ancestors together.
If we want to see the legacies
of slavery and colonialism
in Britain,
we need look no further
than the people.
So my father left Jamaica in 1958,
he came here to live with
his sister and to find work.
He found that experience, as
you can imagine, quite daunting.
He often reminds me of seeing
smoke coming out of a chimney
and him thinking that
the house was on fire.
So he settled here and,
eighteen months later,
he sent for my
mother and my sister.
Jen Reid grew up in Bath,
the only black child at school, where
she regularly encountered racism.
I moved to Bristol in 2012.
You know, I've always been
very aware of what Bristol is,
and it being built
on the back of slavery.
I remember an office
that I had worked in,
directly opposite was Colston
standing proud over Bristol.
The statue that Jen is referring
to was of Edward Colston -
a 17th Century Bristol
merchant and slave trader.
He was a member of the
Royal African Company.
Between 1662 and 1731,
the company transported 212,000
enslaved people across the Atlantic,
of whom 44,000 died en route.
As well as a statue
in the city centre,
schools, streets, and many
other buildings in Bristol
were named after Edward Colston.
When he died he left a lot
of his wealth to charities in Bristol
and it's for that reason
why his name was registered
very largely on the city,
but his larger role
in the trading of Africans
for slavery and slave labour
in the Caribbean
is something that is very
important for us to emphasise
because it speaks to a silence
that often follows
a lot of these figures in history who
were involved in the slavery business
and how that silence is obscured
by this elevation of them
in these other roles that
they performed in their lives.
But on the 7th of June 2020,
in the midst of global protests
against racism,
sparked in part by the murder
of George Floyd
by an American policeman,
protestors in Bristol tore Colston
down from his elevated status,
both literally and figuratively.
Jen Reid and her husband,
Alasdair Doggart, were there -
attending their first ever
political protest.
It was a sight to behold, it was
almost like a carnival atmosphere.
I watched my husband drag
Edward Colston to the water
and throw him in to the water.
It was just such an historic moment.
It was an instinctive action
on my behalf.
As soon as I put my hands on him,
and we started pushing
him towards the water,
then it was as simple as:
"I know how to do that,
I can do that. Let's do it".
Jen's role in the protest renewed her
interest in tracing her family tree.
With the help of the Legacies
of Slavery database at UCL,
she was finally able to find out
more about her family in Jamaica.
What really shook me to the core
was discovering that my great-great-
great-great-great-grandmother
was the first of my ancestors
to be enslaved.
Jen also discovered
that the documents relating
to her 5x great-grandmother
had listed her name as Sylvia.
But that wasn’t her real name.
Like many enslaved people,
she’d been given an English name
by her enslaver -
robbing her of her African identity.
I’ve also discovered that my
grandmother five times removed
had a daughter.
And her daughter had a daughter.
And they were all kept
together by their enslaver,
by the name of Donald McLean.
It made me really angry.
It made me want to research
the McLean clan -
who are they, where are they now
what riches do they have?
A lot of those memories
of slavery are not memories
that are just recorded
and registered in history books
or that are told in classes.
These are memories
that people embody.
They are memories that people carry
from generation to generation.
For Jen’s husband Alasdair,
the Black Lives Matter protests
also triggered an interest
in finding about his past.
When he started looking
into his family history,
he found that he was related
to people with the surname Colston -
though there’s no evidence
that they were connected
to Edward Colston himself.
I think it's a complex picture
when you try to unpick
the detail of everything
about why race
is so important today,
and why people have
to accept the truth
of Britain's involvement
in the slave trade.
I think history
can't be sectioned off
and it's “this is your history,
this is my history”.
It's our history together.
As well as personal connections to
the slave traders and the enslaved,
in Britain there are
deep financial ones.
When slavery in Britain
was abolished in the 1830s,
the government paid £20 million
to slave owners in compensation.
There was no compensation
for the formerly enslaved.
The compensation of £20 million
was really meant to be a form
of reparations to slave owners
for the loss of their
property and people.
An extraordinary figure, and that
even as we consider today
the £20 million,
we should also remember
that it is a fraction
of the full extent of the wealth
earned by enslaved labour
for Great Britain in the entire
period of British slavery.
A lot of that money ended up
being reinvested
in banking, in finance,
in the commercial sector,
but also in
non-commercial activities,
in the arts, and in museums
and even in education
and philanthropic
associations and endeavours.
So there’s clearly a disconnect
between the wealth
that slavery brought to Britain
and the immense suffering inflicted
on those who were enslaved.
In some cases, it’s only names
that can offer clues to the past.
There are threads that are connected
to places and to place names.
Why a plantation in Eastern Jamaica
shares the name
of a location in London,
but there are also threads
that are connected to people.
Why someone in Bridgetown, Barbados,
shares the name
of somebody in Liverpool
even though they have never met.
They are tied to that history
through the history
of slavery and colonialism,
and it is something
that we cannot ignore.
As for Jen, although she knows the
names of her family’s enslaver,
she still doesn’t know her ancestor
Sylvia’s real name,
or anything about
her origins in Africa.
I want to know what tribe
I belong to,
I imagine my tribe to be fearless
because I am fearless,
and I am powerful,
and I imagine my ancestors
to be exactly the same.